welcome back to las vegas now there's
been a dramatic increase in colorectal
cancer cases among young people so dr
steven yates with intermountain
healthcare the sponsors of this next
segment he's here to tell us what we
need to know about colorectal health to
you know prevent this from happening
it's very concerning that this is
increasing in young people sure
colon cancer is the third most common
cancer in the u.s right for men and
women and it's the third leading cause
of cancer-related deaths and it's a
cancer that can be
cured when caught early so the key is
early screening so for younger patients
we're seeing now 10 percent of
colon cancer is in patients that are
less than age 50 wow so when we had been
thinking let's screen at age 50. now
we're saying let's screen it age 45
right right well what are the risk
factors that people have to consider you
know when it comes to colorectal cancer
i know you know maybe family history
what else there are family
hereditary cancers there's something
called lynch syndrome which puts people
at risk for colon cancer okay but in
general you know just getting older
we're more likely to get cancer and
colon cancer is one of those common ones
that if we find it early we're going to
be able to survive it and what are some
of the things that people should look
out for physically
when you know before they get a
screening
so the most common
presentation for patients with colon
cancer
symptoms wise is that the cancer bleeds
and they are anemic so they'll be low on
iron they'll be low on blood they'll
feel fatigued their legs will feel
wobbly or we call them spaghetti legs
sometimes that's what they may feel or
and sometimes they'll they'll notice
that they have blood with their bowel
movements and that's a signal that you
really should be checked having it
checked out yeah it is time to go to the
doctor unfortunately it's time to go to
the doctor speaking of going to the
doctor let's talk screenings how is
intermountain health care helping us
with that here so we have a
strong emphasis to do cancer screening
within our programs we prefer
colonoscopy because it's the best test
for screening but there are other tests
that can be done something called that's
called fit test which is
which is the immunize test of your stool
looking for
uh for blood also you can do the genetic
test
looking for the genetics of cancer cola
guard is the company that's advertised
on television that does that test those
are tests that can be done by
individuals and we do support that in
our intermountain program okay well dr
davis we appreciate everything that
you're doing for us here in the
community you guys make sure you get
your screenings that is so important
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment if you have
any questions and need more information
just simply visit
intermountainhealthcare.org
cancer